congratulations insidious you have
officially become a trilogy now you need
to do what a lot of horror franchises
don't do quit while you're a trilogy
become one of the respected few
insidious chapter three so insidious
chapter 3 is the third insidious movie
it's actually the prequel to the other
insidious movies the main girl's mother
had died before this movie even happened
so I guess she tried to contact her and
now it demons like hey check this out
I'm kind of latch onto her and see what
happens creeping demons now the only one
who can help her is the super awesome
old chick from the other insidious
movies I'm not gonna lie to you a lot of
stuff in this movie worked just movie
did what a movie like this should do it
made you feel helpless like the main
character you just kind of feel at the
whim of this demon but it also
establishes that the demon is not some
Superman it can be beaten just not by
you not right now that's really awesome
there were a few moments in this movie I
was like this is doing what horror
movies usually don't do usually it's
jump scared jump scare jump scare
they're in this movie I'm not gonna say
they're not for every interesting
psychological moment of fear like a
horror movie should have there's a jump
scare to match kind of a byproduct of
the genre at this point but I loved it
this movie had moments of silhouettes
looking at the girl you know and then
they disappear and she's like on the
ground she's looking you see the feet of
the demon walking by her bed that's
really cool man just makes you feel like
you're a child hiding under the bed
scared from a demon cuz we did that when
we were kids and now we're here we are
reliving it as adults and I like the
fact this movie had a good family
dynamic to the relationship but the
father and the daughter it wasn't the
strongest thing I've ever seen but it
did work for this movie just added a
little something extra and it carries
the torch what the other insidious
movies did which is build on the Lord
that they have the insidious movies have
done a good job at establishing this
spectral world that exists parallels our
world yeah I kind of like that
poltergeist reboot insidious does it
better see it like you know the psychic
lady goes into this world like she's
Raziel from legacy at Kane and [ __ ] and
she's walking around it's just like a
creepier version of the world I like
that this movie carried that on it fits
so well with the other insidious movies
it's just great to see a solid trilogy
that's a horror movie where you're like
I could watch this on Halloween have
some friends over and be like hey guys
want to watch the insidious trilogy be a
pretty sweet thing to do let's do that
in Halloween good
insidious you're a good horror movie
trilogy there was a point these guys
came on the scene they're ultimately
like ghost hunters and it's good to see
them in the movie for the sake of it
fitting into the other insidious movie
completing the circle so to speak but
they're seen when they're doing their
Ghost Hunters thing in the house it kind
of took the movie from this really cool
horror movie almost respected dare I say
and took it down to feeling kind of like
Halloween resurrection it felt cheesy it
felt almost like a comedy it felt really
out of place granted the movie addresses
it and uses it and it does shift back
but you can't deny you're like wow is
this is it one of these movies now guys
in the end insidious chapter 3 was what
I wanted it to be and it was more than I
thought it could be the first insidious
was a solid scary movie the second one
made me interested in that world a third
one completes the chapter and now if
they stop at a trilogy I will be happy
they probably won't I will say in cities
chapter 3 it's definitely a good time no
alcohol required yeah my ratings are
still around for those of you who saw my
oh not rant but addressing of the rating
system in my review of spy I didn't say
I was getting rid of it I just wanted to
give you guys some perspective on a
rating system namely mine right guys so
insidious chapter 3 have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more